[Aplausos]
nuestra verdad posible tiene que ser
invención es decir escritura literatura
pintura escultura agricultura
piscicultura todas las duras de este
mundo julio cortázar
soy una persona que tiene relativamente
poco en esta vida y la verdad es que he
venido a aprender he hecho del arte de
la pintura mi vida mi maestro mi camino
al aprendizaje mi inspiración mi motor
de cada día
empecé a pintar a los nueve años con la
inquietud que cualquier niña de esa edad
puede sentir por aprender algo nuevo
y seguir creciendo y seguir pintando en
diferentes clases en casas particulares
en diferentes academias
y eran momentos que me hacían feliz en
los que lo único que me importaba era
crear algo donde solamente estábamos mis
pinceles mis pinturas el lienzo y yo
seguí creciendo y madurando y entré a la
universidad a estudiar psicología la
verdad todavía no sé muy bien por qué
de repente los trazos y los colores
empezaron a hacerme más sentido que
nunca las pinceladas me hacían sentir
viva con ganas de más y en ese momento
me di cuenta que la pintura se había
convertido no sólo en mi más grande
pasión sino en una necesidad
nunca había entendido tanto la
profundidad de la nostalgia hasta que
pinte la mirada perdida de este niño
africano
nunca me había imaginado que la vida
podría ser tan amarilla hasta que
termine el cuadro de este niñito sordo
escuchando por primera vez
nunca me había sentido tan conectada con
la historia de alguien lejano hasta que
pinte cada una de las arrugas en el
retrato de joaquín sabina
nunca pensé que una simple mano me
pudiera representar la esencia de mi
país hasta que pinte este mural las
manos de méxico
el arte me ha dado una visión más
sensible del mundo me ha dado la
capacidad de poder ver la esencia más
profunda de las cosas hoy cuando veo un
atardecer y veo los colores
tan increíbles e irrepetibles en el
cielo
veo arte cuando veo a alguien a los ojos
no puedo evitar ver los mil colores y
brillos que conforman una mirada veo
arte
cuando conozco una persona con un alma
sensible puedo ver arte
el arte me ha ido dando el poder y la
capacidad de transformarme y de
transformar mi realidad
de poder ver las cosas de una forma
distinta y en ese momento las cosas
cambiaron de forma
y trato de hacer de mi vida un arte no
solo cuando estoy frente al lienzo sino
en cada momento de mi vida en cada
decisión que tomo en cada paso que doy
en cada relación que tengo por supuesto
no siempre lo logró pero lucho por
hacerlo porque cuando lo hago mi vida
cambia
hace dos años empecé a dar clases de
pintura con la intención de poder
transmitir la pasión y la satisfacción
tan grandes que siento cuando pinto
llegaron personas que en su vida habían
agarrado un pincel personas que no se
creían capaces de poder crear un cuadro
bonito
personas con un talento impresionante
que todavía no lo habían descubierto y
entonces se fue creando un ambiente de
personas tan diferentes que tenían una
cosa en común el gusto por la pintura se
fueron dando las dos relaciones
conversaciones profundas otras no tan
profundas pero siempre girando en torno
al arte gracias al arte
se fueron expresando sentimientos a
través de los colores y de las formas
y me di cuenta que sí es cierto que el
arte mueve cambia sacude que con el arte
podemos hacer eterno lo pasajero que el
arte es natural y necesario y que el
arte es sobre todo como dice chacal un
estado del alma
cuando hablo de vivir con arte no me
refiero a realizar una actividad
artística como la música o la pintura
hablo de vivir intensamente de vivir
profunda y conscientemente para mí el
arte no es un que no es un algo
para mí el arte es un como una manera de
vivir de ser de pensar y de actuar
bueno creo que lo que es son finitos por
ejemplo los colores las palabras las
notas musicales pero los cómodos la
manera en que un artista puede plasmar y
fundir esos colores
eran que un compositor puede crear
música eso es cómo son arte y eso es
infinito
bueno eric fromm en su libro el arte de
amar explica como las mismas palabras te
amo por ejemplo pueden ser totalmente
triviales o extraordinarias según la
forma en que se digan y es que claro el
cómo hacemos las cosas es muchísimo más
importante que lo que estamos haciendo
el como decimos las cosas le da un
sentido y un significado muy diferente
dependiendo el tono de voz que usemos el
momento en el que lo decimos
creo que tenemos la idea de que la
rutina es algo negativo pero creo que no
creo que la rutina es algo necesario en
nuestras vidas lo que para mí no está
bien es perder la emoción y perder el
sentimiento de realizar una actividad
simplemente porque le hemos hecho por
muchísimos años o porque le vamos a
seguir haciendo por otros más se trata
como les digo de vivir con arte
intensamente disfrutando cada cosa que
hacemos reflejando nuestra esencia en lo
que hacemos descubriéndonos y tratando
de mejorar siempre en cada cosa que
hacemos en la vida
creo que el deber y el placer son dos
experiencias que deben de ser
simultáneas que deben de ser paralelas
no se vale decir me despierto y
bueno voy a trabajar y ya tendré tiempo
el fin de semana o en vacaciones de
disfrutar mi vida se trata de hacerlo
cada día en cada acción y en cada
decisión que tomemos
vuelvo a citar a julio cortázar en su
novela rayuela cuando dice hay que
inventar nuevas pasiones o reproducir
las viejas con pareja intensidad
y es que se trata de encontrar lo
extraordinario en lo ordinario de no
acostumbrarnos de sorprendernos de las
cosas cotidianas y de sentir siempre de
sentir
bueno pablo picasso decía que todos los
niños nacen artistas el problema es que
lo sigan siendo cuando crecen y si
ponemos atención podemos ver como un
niño se desenvuelve de manera totalmente
espontánea un niño no se limita por
prejuicios por miedo a las expectativas
un niño simplemente es refleja su
esencia en lo que hacen sus gestos en
sus movimientos en sus miradas en sus
sonrisas un niño definitivamente vive
con arte
el arte es algo que está en todos
nosotros es algo
es la creatividad de cómo respondemos a
los que es de la vida es nuestro como de
cada día
bueno creo que no hay manera de que si
hacemos algo con el corazón eso no sea
arte
para terminar creo que esta frase
engloba lo que quise decir con mi
plática vivir con arte y es que no
siempre podemos hacer lo que amamos pero
siempre podremos amar lo que hacemos y
eso es arte
[Aplausos]